ils étaient des milliers à avoir répondu
présent pour cette marche blanche en
l'honneur et en l'hommage de ce
professeur d'histoire géographie du
collège de conflans sainte honorine
assassiné vendredi dernier une marche
blanche qui a débuté aux abords du
collège dans les alentours de 18h45 pour
se terminer ici place de la liberté
beaucoup d'applaudissements une minute
de silence en présence de beaucoup
d'élus et surtout du maire de la commune
de conflans sainte honorine je vous
propose d'écouter quelques témoignages
qu'on a pu recueillir avant cortège par
rapport à la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité pour qu'on se rassemble je
pense qu'on a besoin de se rassembler
après avec le co vide on va pas se
mentir c'est un peu compliqué mais voilà
c'est même avec le temps même avec ya
pas d enfin voila c'est important d'être
là on est là pour soutenir pour soutenir
ce professeur pour soutenir d'autres
villes pour soutenir notre démocratie
nos idées enfin bon oui il faut être là
ça a été ressenti vraiment comme un acte
extrêmement extrêmement violent
extrêmement c'est une vie qui est
tranquille
pas de problème d'intégration nous ça
fait 35 ans qu'on vit là il n'y a pas de
problème toutes les communautés dit en
bonne entente et bon voilà c'est une
cata qui arrivent ici quoi donc
bon comme je suis là que pour les gamins
quoi jeu
je veux pas que nos enfants grandissent
dans la haine parce que c'est parti
après pour jamie histoire dans la
créativité donc de faire de belles
choses
il fallait pas aller jusqu'à ce but
c'était un professeur russe pour que
parce qu'il l'a montré des caricatures
de moi mais on a tous eu des professeurs
ou des gens qui nous ont appris des
choses il a été touché d'une manière
horrible d'un geste de barbarie par un
geste de barbarie qui est humain les
yeux et comme l'indiquent ma religion
aussi je trouve ça totalement inhumain
et je viens ici bas tout simplement pour
lui rendre hommage
parce que voilà ça nous touche tous
d'une manière ou d'une autre c'est un
être humain on n'a pas à porter atteinte
à la vie humaine simplement ils étaient
venus nombreux surtout en famille une
présence très remarquée de beaucoup de
collégiens de collège où enseignait ce
professeur et se sont réunis ici sur
cette place de la liberté pour lui
rendent un dernier hommage
un dernier hommage à ce professeur
d'histoire et géographie beaucoup de
parents une marche solennelle beaucoup
de prises de parole et puis de l'émotion
qu'on a pu lire au travers des regards
de certains de ses habitants et beaucoup
de ces familles également un hommage
national sera donné demain à la sorbonne
à partir de 19h30 pour ce professeur
d'histoire géographie